- Arthur Caron souffre
de parperçoit mal des odeurs
connues.
- Ça goûte pas bon,
ça goûte vraiment pas bon.
- L'adolescent était pourtantntt
de contracter la COVID-19.
Maintealimentation se
résume à des barres repas et des
breuvage protéinés. C'est à peu
à avaler.
ARTHUR
- Ça me rend triste,
ça me déprime. Il y a des ment e
parce que j'ai le goût de manger
quelque chose, mais je ne peux
pas parce que ça
- Résultat : il ne mange presque
de kilos en trois mois.
que tous les aliments,
il ne peut plus en manger
Nous a
Les soupers à la table ici,
on n'en a presque plus.iète, sae
les démarches etz-vous
médicaux dans l'espoir de guérir
personne n'a de solution
pour elle. Même l'hôpital
Sainte-Justine, spécialisé danse
ne pasà traiter
de cas similaires.
un spécialiste qui nous prenne
par la main puis qui nous dise :
"Voici, vous allez essayerj'ai n
ment pour vous." Même si
c'est pas encore reconnu, bien,
parce que pour l'instant,
on n'en a pas.
- Elle s'est aus
vers le Dr Yohannes Frasnelli,u.
Il souligne qu'environ 60 %ttttt
la COVID-19 développent
des troubles de l'odorat et
90 % d
relativement rapidement.
Dr JOHANNES FRASNELLI,
professeur d'anatomie, UQAR trèu
de connaissances sur le tr
de l'odorat post-viral chez
c'était extrêmement rare avant.
- Au Québec, il n'existe
aucune clinique spécialisée pout
post-COVID-19, teseseseseseses
adultes que pour les enfants.
frustration et ausi l'angoisse
de cette mère-là et j'espère
qu'on va trouver des solutions.d
impatiemment Art hâte
de recommencer à manger
par sa mère.